this afternoon marks one week since the
mass shooting at a grocery store in
buffalo new york 10 people were killed
13 hurt overall
on friday the first victims of the
hateful racist violence were laid to
rest a funeral service was held for
hayward patterson at lincoln memorial
methodist church where the 67 year old
served as a deacon
today the city will observe 123 seconds
of silence the same length of time
as the attack
at 2 31 pm last saturday police
responded to the calls of shots fired
the target black grocery shoppers in
east buffalo
as we've tried to process the news this
week the accused shooter made his second
court appearance thursday
more details emerged on how he planned
and invited others to watch the attack
and the dispatcher who may have hung up
on the first person to call 9-1-1 was
put on administrative leave
the motive here never seemed in doubt
nor were the bravery
tributes and presidential visit that
quickly followed
hate and fear being given too much
oxygen
by those who pretend to love america
plus of course the questions accusations
and political sparring
like every other time
why weren't warning signs acted on
why was a troubled eighteen-year-old
allowed to purchase weapons of war
what pushed him to act on such hate
questions that have been asked over and
over for the last quarter century as
mass shootings have become a numbingly
familiar part of american life
buffalo is the latest
almost impossible to believe it will be
the last
because while it's easy to choose love
the sad fact is
too many still don't
the 123 seconds of silence will begin at
2 28
57 today and conclude at 2 31 again when
the attack happened that will be
followed
by bells ringing out at houses of
worship
city-wide
at the end of that moment of silence
moments of silence
nancy i know you were
there
immediately after the attack and then
covered it over the weekend and then
into the week it was incredibly
heartbreaking to to see this community
grieving there especially because there
were so many families that were simply
grocery shopping this was a saturday
afternoon and this was such a pillar and
mainstay of the community and you just
think about how people's guards are down
in a moment like that too time and time
again jeffy said at the end there not
choosing love and you are taught hate
you are not born with it